clark county school district principals
already thinking about how to reopen
campuses
the first step to welcoming back some
students in small groups as approved
last week by board trustees 8 news now
reporter kristen drummond speaks with
some principals about their potential
plans and challenges
everybody's circumstances is so unique
as we go through this uncharted
territory
ryan lewis prepares to navigate a new
situation
the gerheim elementary school principal
considers his approach to inviting
some students back on campus in small
groups i like the fact that
we are getting to to tailor it to the
needs of our kids and our communities to
a certain extent
giving principals flexibility when
creating their plans
from the number of children on campus to
who comes back
lewis wants to prioritize special needs
students those
not engaging in classes or are falling
behind
meanwhile principal tam larnard at
spring valley high school
chooses to partly focus on seniors we
want to make sure that
that the circumstances don't prevent
them from reaching their goal and
graduating from high school
but larnard and lewis question certain
issues that includes the district not
providing transportation
the overwhelming majority of my students
are not in walking distance what are the
challenges you've identified at your
elementary school
so the big challenge is just staffing
quite honestly uncertain about how many
teachers may voluntarily come back
principals must also decide when to host
the small groups
it is very possible that students will
have another teacher to serve them
so in my mind it may be more of an after
school thing principal larnard wants to
start surveying teachers this week
regional superintendents must sign off
on each school's plan
kristin drummond 8 news now